merci beaucoup jean pierre bonjour à
tous si j'ai décidé de faire le pas si
j'ai décidé de rejoindre la grande
famille des républicains
c'est parce que j'en suis persuadé
ensemble on peut porter enfin une vision
pragmatique modérée réaliste de
l'environnement avec nicolas on l'a vu
avec le grenelle de la mer le grenelle
de l'environnement on a su en osant avec
de la volonté rassembler est vraiment
faire bouger les choses et c'est ça qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur
aujourd'hui on a vu cette dérive que tu
raconte jean-pierre cette dérive d
écologie ce discours sans cesse alarmant
culpabiliser en donneur de leçons avec
des gens qui sont plus dans une religion
l'écologie une religion de l'écologie
qui est bien différente d'une science de
l'environnement une science de
l'environnement qui prend à la fois
compte des besoins des hommes et de la
société et de l'indispensable nécessité
oui de préserver l'environnement
mais aujourd'hui on ne peut plus opposer
les français les uns contre les autres
on ne peut plus dire qu'il y ait d'un
côté les gentils qui parlerait aux
arbres et de de l'autre les méchants
gaby très dans les villes aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas l'homme animal nuisible d'un
côté et la nature éternelle
laissés-pour-compte de l'autre quand les
écologistes nous disent à la sab le mans
c'était mieux avant j'aimerais bien leur
demander mais avant caen parce que si
c'était avant lorsqu'il ya eu la grippe
espagnole avec près de 30 millions de
morts
si c'était avant avec la grippe est
asiatique avec pas de 4 millions de
morts si c'était avec les dégâts causés
par les tsunamis et autres tremblements
de terre non la nature a pas toujours
été bienfaitrice et l'homme grâce à la
science grâce à la technologie grâce aux
innovations techniques et tous les
progrès qu'on sait mettre en oeuvre
gratte grâce au génie humain
oui on a su faire en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui on a dans nos pays riches
ici en france une espérance de vie qui
croît de 4 heures par jour
alors si le c'était mieux avant c'était
en 1750 où l'espérance de vie tête 27
ans en moyenne
je suis pas certaine qu'ils aient grand
nombre de
certains des donneurs de leçons qu'ils
aient envie de revenir
aujourd'hui l'écologie que nous
souhaitons porter avec notre famille
politique avec vous parce que nous avons
besoin de vous nous avons de wimbledon
vous j'ai besoin de vous pour relayer ce
ce discours modéré c'est une colle et j
qui prennent conscience du monde dans
lequel nous sommes c'est une écologie
qui rime avec économie on a beaucoup
parlé de développement économique
eh bien oui on peut faire en sorte de
préserver l'environnement tout en
préservant notre bonheur de vivre
ensemble avec cette nature aujourd'hui
oui on peut être pêcheur sans être
pilleurs ont peut être armateurs sans
faire de marée noire on peut être
industriels sans forcément être obnubilé
par le greenwashing et évoluer dans la
conception de produits
aujourd'hui le défi que nous avons à
relever tous ensemble avec nos
politiques avec nos idées avec nous avec
nos équipes avec nos territoires avec
nos citoyens ce défi passionnant c'est
le défi de créer un nouveau mode de
développement
un nouveau mode de consommation et ça
c'est possible
c'est possible si nous préférons les
actes au simple profession de foi les
faits au seul principe je suis de ceux
qui pensent qu'il vaut mieux la moitié
de quelque chose que l'intégralité de
rien du tout
aujourd'hui est contre tout ce n'est
plus possible
et pour vous donner un seul exemple
quand on entend nicolas sarkozy ya trois
jours nous parlé sur rtl de fessenheim
eh bien oui aujourd'hui on peut être
écologiste est considéré que le problème
le premier problème celui dont on nous
parle au delà d'interdire le nutella
évidemment le premier problème dont on
nous parle
c'est la conférence sur le climat en fin
d'année cette conférence sur le climat
qui doit mettre d'accord tous les pays
du monde
aujourd'hui la france grâce à son
nucléaire est un pays qui polluent cette
fois moins que l'allemagne qui a une
énergie qui est la moins chère d'europe
qui donne du travail à près de quatre
cent mille personnes en france qui a un
savoir-faire que l'on exporte partout à
travers le monde
aujourd'hui fermer fessenheim alors
qu'on nous dit partout et qu'on va dire
au pays africains où je vous le rappelle
il ya un africain sur trois qui n'a pas
accès à l'eau où il ya les deux tiers
des africains qui n'ont pas accès à
l'énergie où il ya un enfant qui meurt
de faim toutes les cinq secondes à eux
on va dire qu'il faut baisser la
consommation d'énergie et à nous ici on
va nous demander de fermer fessenheim
donc fessenheim au delà de coûter 4
milliards pour sa fermeture alors que
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a indiqué
lequel pouvait continuer à vivre pendant
près de dix ans et que des menus travaux
ont été faits sous la gouvernance de
monsieur hollande aujourd'hui fessenheim
ça nous permet un bénéfice net annuel de
350 millions d'euros
est ce que ces 350 millions d'euros il
ne serait pas plus nécessaire pour
développer les énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui on doit développer les
énergies renouvelables
bien évidemment on doit pouvoir se
passer du nucléaire à terme mais dans
l'état actuel de nos connaissances on ne
peut pas se passer de cette énergie là
et aujourd'hui ne laissons pas la france
au ban de l'économie mondiale ensemble
nous pouvons porter ce projet je le
porte pour ma région paca je voudrais
que ma région paca soit la région
exemplaire société matis qu'elle soit le
porte-drapeau le porte drapeau de cette
nouvelle vision de l'écologie parce
qu'ensemble
comme le dit christian estrosi ça va
changer et avec toi nicolas on sera
derrière toi pour que ça change aussi
en 2007 17 merci